(crowd cheering)
(upbeat music)
♪ I was scared of dentists and the dark ♪
♪ I was scared of pretty girls
and starting conversations ♪
♪ Oh, all my friends are turning green ♪
♪ You're the magician's
assistant in their dream ♪
♪ An ooh ooh ooh ♪
♪ Ooh ooh ♪
♪ And they come unstuck ♪
♪ Lady, running down to the riptide ♪
♪ Taken away to the dark side ♪
♪ I wanna be your left-hand man ♪
♪ I love you when you're
singing that song ♪
♪ And I got a lump in my throat ♪
♪ 'Cause you're gonna
sing the words wrong ♪
♪ Hey ♪
(upbeat music continues)
♪ I just wanna, I just wanna know ♪
♪ If you're gonna, if you're gonna stay ♪
♪ Hey, I just gotta, I just gotta know ♪
♪ I can't have it, I can't
have it any other way ♪
♪ I swear she's destined for the screen ♪
♪ Closest thing to Michelle
Pfeiffer that you've ever seen ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ Lady, running down to the riptide ♪
♪ Taken away to the dark side ♪
♪ I wanna be your left-hand man ♪
♪ I love you when you're
singing that song ♪
♪ And I got a lump in my throat ♪
♪ 'Cause you're gonna
sing the words wrong ♪
(crowd cheering)